[Musik]
bis bald cast ist bei rm unic größte see
also zu in der vorlesung die ich
angekündigt habe einführung in die
philosophie von gottlieb fichte das wird
nicht ganz einfach sein fichte ist kein
ganz eingängiger autor und hat uns auch
an hinterlassen dass die philosophie die
man werde davon abhängen was für ein
mensch man zeit
das ist nicht so zueinander sein dass er
melancholiker eine melancholische
philosophie machen choleriker und
cholerisch oder so sondern es ist so
gemeint dass man entweder wirklich
philosophie machen wollen dann selbst
denke oder nicht
und deshalb sagt er auch mal am beginn
einer vorlesung 1804 seinen hörern ganz
deutlich was hier gesagt wird ist gesagt
und gedacht nur insofern sie meine hörer
das denken dann war noch nicht dabei
damals also es kommt auf sie an was sie
aus dieser vorlesung machen
ich habe ihnen wenn ich mich nicht ganz
top einen überblick geben über die tags
darauf die ich mich einlassen möchte
heute werde ich versuchen sie einmal zu
dem punkt hin zu bringen und wo fichte
selber angefangen hat zu philosophieren
ja
und vielleicht noch einen tipp sie
müssen nicht allzu viel mit schreiben
das wenige was ich ihnen hier vor trage
bin ich auch dabei auszuarbeiten für ein
büchlein das demnächst als im nächsten
jahr dann wahrscheinlich bei suhrkamp
erscheinen werden dann ist es
nachrichten so richtig ist und ich halte
diese vorlesung hier gerade deshalb in
diesem semester weil fichte im am 29
januar des nächsten jahres also 14
seinen 200
todestag zu vergangen hat
beziehungsweise wir haben ihn zu fangen
er kann er nicht mehr diese die
vorlesungen dich hier gehalten habe habe
ich halten werde habe ich etwas kürzer
schon im sommersemester 12 gehalten da
war der anlass der 100 250 geburtstag
fichte ist am 19
1762 in rammenau geboren rand liegt in
der lausitz an so von hier aus gesehen
etwas über dresden hinaus und der
autobahn von meist auch ein schild auf
das schönste barockschloss sachsens
nämlich im rahmen
das stimmt auch dass eine taten schönes
barockschloss da in der nähe ist also
fichte geboren das barockschloss liegt
von dem zentrum des ortes wenn ich die
kirche als das zentrum nehme diese
halten etwa zehn fußminuten weg wichtig
ist also in diesem jahr habe man könnte
das etwas salopp sahen cav geboren jahre
1762 noch in dem krieg wovon dann als
dort außerdem mit krieg verbundenen
wirtschaftlichen not nichts zu merken
war der vater war ein band wirke also
ein ganz kleiner handwerker band werker
waren nicht mal
in einer zunft organisiert also er war
zunächst in pulsnitz tätig hat dort
seine spätere frau kennen gelernt
johanna schurig hat sie an erster
november 17 61 geheiratet und aus den
daten können sie ersehen also wichtig
ist vor der eheschließung gezeugt worden
und der vater wollte die einstellung
nicht so hat das richte das riecht es
schon stimmt nicht der vater war schon
längst tot der brautvater und man ist
dann also ausgezogen auf das dorf
rammenau also eine kirche drei häuser
und sowas viel mehr war nicht da und
dann in einiger entfernung das schloss
nun der eine anekdote erzählt bei der
geburt fichte ein entfernte voran sein
onkel vorbeigekommen und habe prophezeit
das kind werde also ein großes leben
haben die anekdote richtet fichtes sohn
in der ersten auflage seiner
lebensbeschreibung in der zweiten
auflage gestrichen
diesmal etwas belastet gott so erinnert
wir wollen diese anekdote sehr an die
geschichte von greisen simeon im zweiten
lukas kapitel die mutter schildert
fichte in seinen wenigen zeugnisse
hinterlassen hat bezüglich seiner eltern
als wenig fröhlich fast nie vielleicht
auch etwas depressiv das weiß ich nicht
den charakter des vaters schildert er
als einen hellen charakter und einen
mann von forschenden geist die personen
flüchteten von beiden etwas mitbekommen
der vater hat das gilt lesen und
schreiben gelehrt das war damals wohl so
mythen möglichst schuljahr gab es wohl
nicht und er hat dem kind auch ein buch
einmal geschenkt dass es geht sehr
fasziniert hat und ihn so fasziniert
dass er für kaum etwas anders noch augen
und ohren hat er daher dass in den bach
geworfen
es zeigt sich also sehr früh bei diesem
kind ein streben nach selbstständigkeit
und das blieb ihm auch erhalten das
große ereignis das mich das leben
wirklich ganz massiv bestimmt hat wird
in einer elektrode zählt das mag ein
bisschen ausführlich sein aber
jedenfalls die grundzüge müssen stimmen
der pfarrer dass auch das rennen war
wegen seiner predigten berühmt der graf
der bereiten sind schloss saß hatte
einen freund der ihn besuchen wollte und
bei der gelegenheit die sonntags politik
des pfarrers hören wollte
eine front karmann als die predigt
vorbei war
dann hat man ihm gesagt dass er gar
nicht so schlimm man habe da irgendwo
ein kleines büchlein das könne die
predigt wiederholen
das muslim war der junge fichten und in
der tat hat man ihn dann ins schloss
geworden die predigt also wiederholt
sinngemäß richtig und auch mit
bibelzitaten und soll also das war eine
intelligenz leistung von einem etwa acht
bis zehnjährigen kind daraufhin hat sich
dieser besuch ein freiherr von miltitz
wollen uns ein verwandter von novalis
also dem friedrich von hardenberg dieser
miltitz hat sich also entschlossen dem
kind eine seiner begabung angemessene
ausbildung zu ermöglichen möchte kann
zunächst dann zu einem pfarrer der ihnen
etwas unterrichtet hat dann auf meisten
auf die lateinschule dass man so das
übliche und dann kann er auf
die erste schule porter vorteil liegt in
der nähe von naumburg sind zwei große
philosophen 14 gegangen
der erste war so fichte und der zweite
später wird euch nichts also eine
berühmte schule man doch die fichte
sechs ja das war so die regel und zwar
ging man am soundsovielten des jahres
rhein blieb sechs jahre und ging genau
am soundsovielten des nächsten jahres
raus und fichte kann also im herbst in
die schule
im oktober musste dazu übrigens noch das
stadtrecht das bürgerrecht einer anderen
stadt oschatz erwerben das heißt das hat
mich wohl für ihn gemacht und denn um
auf diese schule zu kommen musste man
bürger in einer bestimmten stadt die
städte hatten das recht 234 je nach dem
buben auf diese schule dann zu schicken
also er hat diese schule sucht an
sozusagen abitur gemacht und fing dann
also mit 18 jahren das studium an ein
paar sollten zum tochter gelernt das war
das übliche erstens mal latein
zweitens griechisch drittens hebräisch
die schule wird von sohn fichtes im
grunde als sehr unaufgeklärt und am
streng geschildert das mag von der
perspektive des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
aus auch richtig gewesen sein
aus der perspektive des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts nicht sie war schon
durchaus aufgestellten dass sie noch
einige fehler wenn man so nah dran das
hat also jetzt ein ist all jenen
erforscht ziehen heißt er also es wurden
durchaus zb lässige texte gelesen und es
war nicht so dass man nun nur alte
lateinische
autoren lesen durfte man durfte auch
etwa wie gesagt lessing lesen und danach
durch schlecht singen ist natürlich der
streit mit götze bekannt geworden also
die streitsache wo es eigentlich schon
um ein aufgeklärtes denken in bezug auf
die biblische überlieferung ging es gibt
noch einige anekdoten die ich vielleicht
jetzt besser über angehe fichte kann
dann also 1768 auf die universität er
studierte wohl in wittenberg jena und
leipzig unserer theologie und juristerei
aus dem studium wird nicht richtig was
waren studien ich verdienen heutzutage
wird man in einen studienabbrechern
einen ersten bericht starb die
unterstützung durch die familie gehörte
auf und dann musste er sich also auch
nicht nur uns studieren kümmern sondern
ums geld aber es scheint doch nicht so
richtig alles sein fall gewesen zu sein
also das studium a nix besonders häufig
denn intelligenter mensch intelligente
menschen fragen nach gründen und gründe
ergeben aus gründen ergeben sich dann
auch notwendigkeiten also wenn das und
das gehört dann folgt und so kommt
fichte darauf dass da eigentlich das
leben bestimmt zeit und gründe
und wenn es durch kunde bestimmt ist
dann und zwar total bestimmt ist
dann gibt es eigentlich keine
selbständigkeit dann folgt die haltung
die man determinismus nimmt alles ist
terminiert also auch nennen will ist der
manierlich kommen
heer aus bestimmten gründen nicht der
manieren schwarze ich jetzt anderthalb
stunde und dann gehe ich wieder aus
bestimmten gründen und so weiter und sie
genauso das wäre also dann determinismus
sie können sich vorstellen dass bei
einem menschen der ein starkes
selbständigkeit streben hat das hatte ja
wichtig ich habe schon immer versucht
david zu zeigen dass der also in
probleme kommt teils mit sich selbst
teils auch dann mit dem was er so denkt
das dauert so einige jahre wichtig nimmt
dann so die existenz eines hofmeisters
an was man darunter zu verstehen als
kennen sie vielleicht durch die dichtung
von lenz das ist nicht kennen also hegel
und hölderlin haben etwa dieselbe
situation gehabt ein hofmeister ist also
ein junger mann der sein studium hinter
sich gebracht hat auf jeden fall ein
gutes stück weiter ist und er dann
entweder mit jungen leuten auf die
universität geht uns jedoch bereitet
denn mit damen aus dem studium was recht
ist wird oder auch die kinder anderer
leute unterrichtet es hat also die
stimmung und mehrfach gemacht er war
also dann hofmeister wie gesagt er lebte
am rande des existenzminimums und das
hat ihnen auch eines tages so weit
gebracht dass er mit freitag gedanken um
ging dann am sonnabend vor seinem
geburtstag dann hat er lebte damals in
leipzig einen brief eines bekannten
gefunden möchte noch sofort zu ihm
kommen hat er gemacht der hat ihm dann
eine stelle vermittelt es war gebeten
worden jemanden zu suchen der hans
hoffmeister tauglich sei
vermittelt also eine stelle nach zürich
zur familie
sie sind das wirrköpfe gewesen dass
gaster steht heute noch das können sie
sich ja seit jahrhunderten keinen krieg
mehr erlebt das haus steht also noch und
fichte geht also nach geht geht zu fuß
von leipzig nach zürich und was soll wir
machen
endlich haben muss er halten oder die
kutschen leben das kostet geld oder wie
geht's zu fuß
und das zu fuss nach zürich gegangen hat
dann die stelle angetreten und lernt
nicht nur die familie ott kennen sondern
auch die familie eines meisters 1
weltmeister ist also jemand der über die
wagen zu achten auf die wagen zu achten
hat das richtig geworfen wird eine hohe
stellung in zürich ist der mann dessen
schwester übrigens mit klopstock
verheiratet werden im hause wann kennen
lernt fichten die tochter des hauses
kennen die den haushalt führt war die
deren mutter schon länger verschoben
und das obwohl zwischen den beiden
richtungen und johanna rahn johannes
gefunkt und sie verloren sich und
während das verhältnis zu der familie
ort immer schlechter wird und dann löst
sich diese verbindung unter anderem auch
deshalb wird das verhältnis schlecht wer
fichte wiederum darauf insistiert dass
die kinder nicht nur etwas auswendig
lernten zb den katechismus sondern
wirklich begriffen was sie denn da nun
lernen sollten
und das selber den richten kurz und gut
es kam zur auflösung fichte geht nach
leipzig zurück kommt dann bald in
geldnot und dann passiert was ganz
seltsames dann kommt ein student zu ihm
und sagte er hätte gerne
nachhilfe na also will nachhilfe haben
und erhält sagt wichtig darüber will an
nachhilfe haben für nachhilfe haben über
kant der offensichtlich wichtel bis
dahin oberfläche nicht bekannt waren
ganze das war im sommer 1790 möchte
setzt sich also hin und liest ganz damit
er die stunden noch geben kann
und zuerst die kritik der reinen
vernunft dann die praktischen das letzte
wird für ihn zum entscheidenden erlebnis
seines lebens zurück zur kritik der
reinen vernunft zunächst der sand also
die kritik der range von uns kennen was
macht kann es da
das muss ich ihnen jetzt etwas
ausführlicher sagen weil das wirklich
das ab sprungbrett ist für richter also
kritik der reinen vernunft analysiert
unser wissen und zwar insofern sich
unser wissen auf alles das was wir
sinnlich wahrnehmen können
besiegt und das was wir sinnlich
wahrnehmen kann die welt ganz ganz wie
wahrscheinlich sie auch die natur also
nicht die natur im gegensatz zur kultur
also dieses haus hier ist auch ein stück
natur insofern wird sinnlich wahrnehmen
können und dieses haus unterliegt
natürlich auch dann naturgesetzen
genauso gut wie die bäume da draußen und
also ganz analysiert unser wissen von
der natur dieses wissen hat notwendige
strukturen sonst könnten wir uns ja gar
nicht deren orientieren also die tafel
da ist eben für uns vor der wand uns
nicht hinter der wandel nicht auf da
waren sondern sind hängt davor
wenn wir so was sagen dann brauchen wir
begriff und zwar formale begriff denn
dann unterscheiden wir die tafel von der
wand verwenden ganz ohne darauf zu
reflektieren den begriff der differenz
des unterschiedes und die tafel nehmen
wir als eine einheit und die wand neben
der würzner einheit das sind also
begriffe einheiten differenz die wir bei
allem was wir wahrnehmen nolens volens
in gebrauch nehmen müssen solche
begriffe also braucht unser bewusstsein
damit wir überhaupt wissen und etwas in
unserem wissen festhalten können
solche strukturen wie differenz und
identität zeigen sich in unseren
urteilen
wir teilen also wenn ich sage die wand
die tafel steht vor der wand dann habe
ich einen im formalen technologischen
sinne ein urteil abgegeben und diese
urteile haben strukturen also wie gesagt
ein haltloser differenz oder grund und
folge oder wechselbeziehung substanz und
aktie werden sie uns englische mehr ganz
kind dieser struktur und zwölf das sind
die so genannten kategorien und die
garantieren eben dass wir urteilen
können und weil wir urteilen können
können wir auch allgemein verbindlich
reden sonst hätten wir immer nur die
aussage
das ist so das ist so und das ist so
die kategorien garantieren uns also dass
wir erfahrungen machen können
zur erfahrung gehört ja dass das eine
zum anderen hinzutritt und dass wir
etwas als regelmäßig ansehen
wir sehen uns die bedingung der
möglichkeit unseres handelns wenn wir
nicht voraussetzen dass die bänke hier
stehen blieben
dann könnten wir ja gar nicht hier uns
reinkommen und uns hier hinsetzen
wir brauchen also eine gewisse feste
ordnung die wir unreflektiert
voraussetzen damit wir überhaupt etwas
in dieser welt tun verändern können
diese ordnung der dinge nennt kant
erfahrung und mit recht in unserer
erfahrung basiert darauf dass eben die
dinge sich wiederholen weil sie
bestimmten grund gesetzen folgen
das garantiert zugleich dass wir über
die dinge objektiv reden können und
verbindlich reden können
ihr urteil und werden wir auch tun
müssen wir über etwas orten sind also
für kant unsere sinnlichen wahrnehmungen
die daten die wir portal
wir können aber die daten nicht
schlichtweg bruchteilen sondern sie sind
für uns ja auch geordnet also mein
sprechen hören sie jetzt in der zeit
nach und nach abbauen und zeit sind
ordnungen in denen wir wahrnehmen und
sie sind feste ordnungen
das heißt wir in unserem bewusstsein
orten alles das habe ich hier erlebt
dass dort das zuerst und dann das andere
um zeit also sind formen in denen wir
wahrnehmen kann sagt anschauungs formen
wobei das noch anschauung nicht auf das
optische beschränkt ist es braucht also
zur erkenntnis zwei jahre einmal unser
denken in kategorien unser urteilen und
dann daten also hast du zum beispiel
darum die dafür da ist grün die wann das
weiß und wenn sie daraus ein ort machen
wollen dann sagen sie die tafel ist grün
dazu benutzten sie sich die struktur der
substanz akzidenz kategorie die substanz
tafel hat das akzidenz grün nicht wahr
was machen wir da denken wir nicht
reflexiv darüber nach das macht die
logik beziehungsweise die philosophie
zu den kategorien gehört ja auch die
kausalität und die wird jetzt wichtig
weil ich schon sagte fichte ja dem
determinismus anhin das wissen wir aus
briefen die er geschrieben hat so einen
salat sie kennen veröffentlichungen man
so was also nach dem gesagten ist
kausalität eine form in der wir urteilen
und sie gilt also allgemein und in der
tat für urteilen ja auch dass die dinge
in der natur nach kausal gesetzen sich
vollziehen zumindest also die hacker in
der für uns wahrnehmbaren welt
mikroskopischen bereich passieren andere
sachen
ich gehe jetzt so wenn das gilt und
unser handeln auch kausal bestimmt ist
dann sind wir in der tat nicht frei und
determinismus gilt so jetzt gehe ich
noch mal zurück an den anfang bei kannte
analysiert also das wissen die
erkenntnis wir wissen von den dingen
dieser welt und so beispielsweise jetzt
dass wir hier in einem hörsaal sitzen
und der sohn so ausgestattet ist das
müssen wir
wir können über die dinge doch nur reden
wenn wir sie im bewusstsein haben oder
wir schwarzen donnerstag
anders wenn wir also die dinge im
bewusstsein haben können wir über sie
reden sonst ist das reden sinnlos oder
geschwätz natürliche bewusst sein sagt
da sind die dinge und mein bewusstsein
kommt hinzu es stellen sich immer vor
der satz würde stimmen
die dinge sind da und mein bewusstsein
kommen zu den dingen hinzu was machen
wir denn dann behaupten wir doch dass
die dinge da sind woher wissen wir denn
das doch wohl durch unser bewusstsein
und nicht durch die dinge die da sind
also unser bewusstsein ist das erste und
dann wissen wir von dem was in unserem
bewusstsein auftaucht und sonst können
wir gar nicht vernünftig darüber reden
also ist es unser bewusstsein der
ausgangspunkt der philosophie das ist
nicht neu bei qantas schon latte krachte
und weil führen ebenfalls dann liegt
aber auch wenn unsere bewusstsein der
ausgangspunkt ist die reihe der
kategorien in unserem bewusstsein ist
sozusagen die struktur unseres sinnlich
wahrnehmbaren bewusstsein
unser schon ziemlich wahrnehmen denn
bewusstseins
in unserem wissen von den dingen die wir
entnehmen ist also kausal bestimmt unser
wissen von den dingen ist kausal
bestimmt weiter als dazu dass sie
kategorien die dinge die wahrnehmungen
ordnung gehen sie nicht
das heißt also das könnte einen bereich
geben in dem die streckte kausalität
nicht gewillt das wäre aber nicht der
bereich der sinnlichen wahrnehmung
es gibt also wie kant auch dann in der
kritik der reinen vernunft in der
dialektik in mazedonien kapitel zeigt
die möglichkeit von freiheit nicht die
wirklichkeit das zeigt sich anderswo
viel wenn also freiheit ist dann muss
man das tun was er von seiner
philosophie sagt ich musste das wissen
begrenzen also die grenzen des wissens
aufzeigen
das theoretische wissen ist das wissen
von natur nicht so dass alles so
deutlich gesehen hat wie ich es jetzt
versucht es ihnen zu sagen weiß ich
nicht jedenfalls er geht nach der kritik
der reinen vernunft sehr schnell und 1x
zur kritik der praktischen von und über
vermutlich einfach auch weil er raus
musste und die kritik der praktischen
vernunft
es ist nun die wirklichkeit von
freiheits behauptet nicht die
möglichkeit die kritik daran von und
zeigt kann nur die möglichkeit zeigen
weil ihr gegenstand das müssen von natur
ist
der determinismus dem fichte anhängt
sagt alles ist verursacht alles ist
bedingt alles ist wirkung eine ursache
das gilt für die natur auch noch ganz
der determinismus behauptet diese
determination durchgängig wenn aber die
kategorien nur sinnvoll angewendet
werden können oder gebraucht werden
können und sinnlich wahrnehmbare zu
hören sie viele nutzer pp zu ordnen und
darüber zu urteilen dann gilt die
kausalität eben nur für dieses dann ist
also ein bereich da der offensichtlich
ein bereich gedacht werden der nicht
bedingt ist qualität bedingt immer die
ursache ist immer durch die wirkung
bedingt geht gar nicht anders
gegenteil von bedingungen wäre also
freiheit gibt es denn so was
die freiheit also in der natur gibt es
freiheit nicht vielleicht gibt es zufall
aber keinen freiheit in unserem
bewusstsein gibt es aber etwas was
unbedingt ist nach kant und das ist das
bewusstsein unserer pflicht wenn sie das
wort das war pflicht hat so heutzutage
etwas wie soll ich sagen ja unangenehm
ist an sich das sieht so nach drill und
noch was aus und viele leute haben sich
auch ihre verbrechen dadurch zu
rechtfertigen versucht dass sie sich auf
ihre pflicht beriefen
das ist bekannt nicht gemeint bekannt
ist gemeint dass bewusstsein dessen was
wir sollen oder dürfen wir auch nicht
dürfen
es ist für jeden von uns als simpel zu
sagen doch klar dass wir hier nicht
einfach einen anderen menschen umbringen
so offen
das ist eindeutig und zwar nicht deshalb
weil wir vielleicht dann gepackt und ins
gefängnis gesteckt würden sondern weil
es einfach menschenunwürdig erst einen
menschen umzubringen
ein solches bewusstsein nimmt kann
pflicht
ich weiß das darf ich nicht dass ich
wenn ich's umkehren soll
ich habe den anderen menschen als wesen
das um seiner selbst willen geliebt und
existiert zu achten
die formulierung die am anfang unseres
grundgesetzes steht die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar ist sicher aus
kantischen geist formuliert worden
also unser bewusstsein unsere pflicht
ist nach kant unbedingt und weil wir
dieses bewusstsein haben
deshalb können wir uns selbst als solche
die frei auf diese verpflichtung
reagieren verstehen also zuerst das
bewusstsein der pflicht das macht uns
bewusst dass wir frei sind ja oder nein
zur pflicht sagen können im übrigen
kommt noch dazu dass erst das
bewusstsein von pflicht aber habt uns
eine alternative des handelns eröffnet
sonst würden wir als natur wissen und
seinen instinkten und trieben folgen
könnten sowas neigung
es ist noch wichtig dass man dass ich
hier mit der abspann von ganz wichtig
klar wird dass ich darauf eingehen
worauf sich genau die verpflichtung
bezieht bekannt sie bezieht sich nicht
in erster linie auf die handlungen
sondern auf die willens bestimmungen zur
handlung teilnehmer feucht hat heute
morgen her kommen wollen
sie habe auch ich muss mich da s bahn
fahren hier stellen sich vor
das ding hätte halbe stunde darum
gestanden und ich hätte es nicht kommen
können dann hätte ich ihnen doch nichts
über sein zug oder nichts böses muss ich
sagen zugefügt weil ich zwar kommen
wollte aber de facto nicht kommen konnte
ich bin also meine verpflichtung nicht
eingegangen bin
die vorlesungen zu halten wäre ich dann
durchaus noch nachgekommen
eingestiegenen die s bahn aber das blöde
ding steht jetzt da kann ich nicht
führen
also es kommt nicht darauf an dass die
handlung besteht sondern dass ich die
handlung will und das tue was ich als
wollen da tun kann
also wenn sie examen machen wollen und
dazu nicht das nötige arbeitspensum
aufbringen ja dann haben sie auch nicht
ihr examen machen wollen
das ist vielleicht geträumt sich gar
nichts machen geht nicht also
so wenn jetzt die verpflichtung als
unbedingt begriffen wird und wir die wir
eine verpflichtung folgen oder nicht
folgen können darin als frei uns ansehen
müssen
dann sind wir also solche die das liegt
im begriff der freiheit aus sich selbst
handeln können nichts bestimmt nicht zum
handeln außer ich mich selbst das sage
danke ich bin frei das heißt nicht dass
ich in die manche dinge in meinem
überlegen 17 einbeziehen muss das was
anderes so licht taucht im bewusstsein
auf als ein gebot kanzler-gattin
imperativ du sollst und sieht auch so
aus dass sie sich den teufel darum
schert ob mir das passt oder nicht
das kann bis zum bitteren ende sein
können hier unten das denkmal für die
restlose also ob mir das passt oder
nicht
pflicht ist gültig für jeden
sie ist also insofern günstig als wir
vernünftig gewesen sind und wenn wir
nicht vernünftig gewesen sind hätten wir
keine pflichten
mein hund hat grippe
hatte ich also das hängt mit unserer
vernunft zusammen
da wir keinen weiteren grund haben auf
die wir nicht zurückführen können sie
ist verpflichtung durch die vernunft
selber und deshalb heißt das wo er
kritik der praktischen vernunft nämlich
der vernunft insofern sie uns zum
handeln bestimmt etwas genauer gesagt zu
willens bestimmungen bestimmt die uns
bestimmung ist das entscheidende
daraus folgt unser handeln also wer
gebietet nicht der mensch sondern die
vernunft gebietet das was wir tun sollen
deshalb ist die ausrede der hat mein
mann oberst hat mir gesagt ich soll
falsch ich bin immer noch für das
verantwortlich was ich tun dass die
vernunft keinen weiteren grund hat uns
zu gebieten heißt dass sie also von sich
selber her selbst gebietes erst dann ist
die vernunft nicht irgendetwas was wieso
einer tafel da an der wand stellt darum
oder so also ist das was wir vorziehen
wenn wir selber nachdenken wenn wir
nachdenken was wir tun sollen
von dort ist nicht etwas vernunft ist
aktivität server unser geistiges sich
bewegen
die kritik der reinen vernunft muss für
den jungen mann fichte gerade zu einer
offenbarung gewesen sein
also er schreibt einem freund ich liebe
in einer neuen welt seitdem ich die
kritik der praktischen von uns gelesen
aber ähnliche äußerungen gibt es
mehrfach kommt vom märz haben wir bei
gewonnen schreibt da einmal kopf und
herz waren genau bei ihm auseinander
gerissen
der kopf sagte ich bin sehr terminiert
das herz sagte und eine nenne ich will
mich selber bestimmen
jetzt hat er eine möglichkeit gefunden
dass der für die vernunft dasjenige
bestätigt was er doch eigentlich selber
im sich fühlt und man merkt
selbständigkeit
das muss wird nicht nur offenbar für ihn
gewesen sein die kritik der praktischen
vernunft
obwohl seine wirtschaftliche not
durchaus bleibt man ist der ton seiner
briefe wie verwandelt
können sie selber nachlesen die briefe
fürchtest du in der fichte gesamtausgabe
veröffentlicht was können sie nach dem
tief unter können sie nachlesen
also er ist auf einmal wie umgewandelt
geradezu
er lebt für man kann es fast wirklich
sagen ein neues leben und dann
beschäftigte sich ausführlich mit der
kritik der reinen von uns damit der
kritik der urteilskraft der dritten
großen politik von kampf und schreibt
doch da einige texte zu naja also viel
geld hat er nicht und als in der stelle
dann mal in warschau angeboten wird als
hofmeister geht er nach warschau
auch wieder zu fuß
da bleibt er aber nicht sehr lange denn
es stellt sich nach kurzer zeit raus
dass die patrone im wasser und licht
selber an sich gar nicht gut verstehen
und er nimmt seinen abschied und der
zurück nach deutschland und reinhold
können verraten wohin geht nach
königsberg natürlich er geht nach
königsberg und kann zu sehen
dann wirst du auch das war damals so
üblich bitte stellen sie sich mal diese
zeit vor
das fällt uns ja etwas schwer also wir
steigen ins flugzeug dann 72 stunden in
hamburg seien eine stunde vielleicht in
rom oder so damals konnte man entweder
zu fuß gehen reiten oder mit der kutsche
fahren mehr gab es nicht
das heißt die leute sind rings nicht so
um gereist wie wir also gutes reisen
nach italien sind ja bekannt
weil das so schwierig war dahin zu
kommen wir uns mal auf reisen aus zum
teil auch gefahr von auch welchen räuber
und solche geschichten wäre an der
kutsche konnten brechen und so weiter
sagt man also liebe geschichten
das heißt also man reiste links dich so
viel wie wir heute uns bewegen
das heißt also umgekehrt wenn ein
bekannter mensch irgendwo hin kam dann
besucht der andere bekannte menschen
und selbst wenn man aus relativ
einfacher unbekannter menschen irgendwo
hinkommen wie der junge fichten sind
kein mensch kennt wenn dann nach
königsberg kommt und kann zu kampf geht
dann wird da mal eingeladen
das ist üblich damals und ist auch eine
form von kommunikation sich unter diesen
verhältnissen geradezu aufdrängt das
versteht man sehr gut wird also eher
kommt man zu kant besucht ihn und dann
passierte das was immer wieder passiert
dass es geld geht ihm aus dann wendet er
sich an kant mit der bitte um ein
darlehen und er hat man gerade an einem
manuskript rom geschrieben und das liegt
eher bei damit der kann doch sieht dass
er wenn er irgendwas light also nicht
gerade dem letzten deppen wasser halten
was tut kommt hilfsbereitschaft wird
ausgesprochen immer sehr unternehmen zur
metaphysik der sitten als eine
pflichtabgabe
er verleiht kein geld da sei nicht
hilfsbereit
doch er gesagt dem wetter so fichter ein
seitdem also geld kriegst du nicht junge
aber das manuskript was sie dabei gelegt
haben junge mann das ist gut
damit können sie ihr geld verdienen
ich vermittle das an meinem verleger der
druck das und ich werde auch mit ihm
reden beziehungsweise schreiben dass sie
in forschungs kriegen was kann da
gemacht hat
war ganz im sinne seiner kritik daran
von praktischen vernunft
er hat geholfen und zwar so dass seitdem
immer geholfen hat nicht einfach die
abhängigkeit vergrößert indem man ihm
geld gibt das ja dann doch nicht
zurückzahlen kann
sondern er hat sich auf die eigenen
beine gestellt es ist so gekommen wie
kant voltaire hat zu tun sagt er ja dass
es dem verleger das buch empfohlen der
druck dass auch und wichtig zugang
vorschuss also die hilfe die hand
gegeben hat war weitaus vernünftiger als
die geschichte erbeten hat hat ihn auf
die eigenen beine gestellt das ist doch
der sinn von hilfe dass jemand haus sich
selber was tun kann
fischer hat das kaum glauben wollen
so verständlich so kann es gibt nichts
größeres auf dieser welt für kampf für
fichte
wer sagt das manuskript ist gut der
junge mann kann das kaum glauben aber
immerhin er macht das manuskript fertig
es geht in dem druck und jetzt kommt
noch ein ereignis echtes leben das auch
märchenhafte züge geradezu hat ähnlich
wie seine entdeckung durch den freigang
von mit sitz an der verleger wer war das
was man ein schlitzohr nimmt
in dem ruf stehen verleger immer das
buch von rechte hat er den titel versuch
einer kritik aller offenbarung sie
wissen kann hatte schon drei kritiken
rausgebracht
das wort kritik deutet also auf kannte
das buch war ebenfalls in klassischer
manier und sektion geschrieben
das ist das erste was fast das erste was
richtig geschrieben hat das ist
vielleicht als nicht ganz sicher einmal
wegen der autorschaft gibt es einige
rezensionen die könnten von fichten
seien dies nicht abzuweisen dass ich von
ihm sind sie sehr wohl nicht zu beweisen
aber sonst ist das so das erste was so
scheint es hat also in kantischen stil
klassischer manier und aber ganz im ghan
zwischen geist und macht diese verleger
er druckt zwei titelblättern 1 mit dem
verfasser namen - vertreibt er in
königsberg und umgebung und 1 ohne
verfasser namen das wird treibt er im
heiligen römischen reich deutscher
nation so hieß ja damals die politische
einheit
es kam was kommen musste
das buch wurde für und kantig schuss
gehalten und zwar nicht etwa von dummen
leuten sondern es war durchaus von
goethe schiller oder von jemandem der
schon als interpret und weiter denke
ganz bekannt geworden war
reinhold heißt die sammlung
wichtiger mann im übergang von ganz zum
deutschen idealismus
die haben das buch wie ein klassisches
gehalten und auch entsprechend wurde
dieses buch rezensiert solche rezension
ist natürlich der noch ganz zu gesicht
bekommen
und das wo sie so aus der messe
erschienen also etwa im mai die
ostermesse es nicht selbst ostern diesen
wochen nach ostern also düster for peace
und das buch erschienen also kannst
kommen hat dann die rezensionen dass
eine für fichte durchaus ehrenvolle
erklärung in die allgemeine literatur
zeitung gesetz diejenige allgemeine
literatur -zeitung hatte unter anderem
eine rezension
die qantas verfasser dieses buches nennt
angeschrieben und war die literatur
zeitung deutschlands also wenn ein buch
erschienen ist dass einiges gewicht
hatte wurde das in der jenischen
allgemeine literatur zeitung rezensiert
sie war 1785 begründet worden um der
kantischen philosophie zum durchbruch zu
verhelfen kann nennt also fichte als
autor
damit ist der jungstar der philosophie
also wenn sie an unseren jungs stand
markus gabriel denken dass weit bereitet
mich dass das ist wie wenn jemand als
jemand erscheint der ihn der wie kann
schreibt also erstickt
auf einmal
er ist fichte selber ist inzwischen noch
einmal hauslehrer in kroko dass ich dem
heutigen polen damals in ostpreußen und
kündigt nach einiger zeit
er hat sich also in leipzig waren
nochmals gerade bevor wir etwas von
seiner braut dieser johanna entlobt
vermutlich wir wissen es nicht genau
weil rahmen in vermögensverluste kam und
fichte vielleicht den rahmen mich auch
noch mit einer armen kirchenmaus dir
selber war belasten wollte wir wissen es
nicht ganz genau jedenfalls er und seine
braut finden wieder zueinander und dann
geht fichte nach zürich und anderen
heiratet dann auch im späten november
1791 jahren bevor er sich auf diesen weg
macht schreibt er ein kampf gegen die
unterdrückung der pressefreiheit vor
allen dingen gegen das sogenannte
wöllner schickt weil manchmal minister
den preußen und hat seinen weg bis er
hat auch damit zu tun gehabt gegen die
pressefreiheit der mann tätig also
schreibt ein panzer gegen uns
rückforderungen der denkt freiheit von
den fürsten europas die sie bisher
unterdrückten und er schreibt ebenfalls
ein buch das spielt in seinen späteren
leben noch eine rolle beitrag zur
berichtigung der ortszeitung des
publikums über die französische
revolution es gerade der anfang der 90er
jahre und die revolution begann
wissen 89 das buch erscheint übrigens zu
einem zeitpunkt wo sich deutschland
schon von der revolution abzuwenden
fichter also wie gesagt ist in
ostpreußen tätig und dann macht das ich
also auf den weg nach zürich und auf
diesem weg versucht da dann wie ich
ihnen eben schon gesagt habe das war
üblich alle möglichen leute und dann
wird er selber auch gerne empfangen
inzwischen ist im drohen voraus und
kommt unter anderem auch nach jena und
wird dort zur mitarbeit an der jüngeren
allgemeine literatur zeitung eingeladen
und er geht auch auf diese einladungen
ein schreibt dann zwei rezensionen schon
mal also nicht so wichtig sind
wichtigsten schon aber nicht so wichtig
weil ich dieses darauf eingehen wollte
und dann kommt also damit dass es hier
hast 93 in zürich an die lage die
wirtschaftliche lage der familien hat
sich inzwischen stabilisiert und dann
kann er heiraten und macht das dann auch
das ist also im spätjahr 1793 ich sagte
ihnen zwei rezensionen hat er gemacht
für die jenisch und es wurde ihm doch
eine dritte aufgetragen und die sorte
entscheidend werden für ihn und darauf
man sich jetzt auch investor stunde
wollen noch eingehen
das war ein buch das anliegen erschienen
war
von einem job ernst schulze der war
professor in jena solche anonymität 'nen
halten sich nicht
lange aber immerhin dass die maschine
anonym und hatte war betitelt mit dem
namen eines antiken skeptiker sandys
idee muss so hieß der mann also der
schulze werden wir sind niemals schwarze
genannt sollte war alle skeptiker
das sagt s titel wort schon und er
richtet sich gegen die rheinhessische
vernunft reinholz dass man sich jetzt
ein bisschen ausführlicher darauf
eingehen
mein holz hatte zunächst sich gegen
pfand gestellt rheine zwar einen bei
einer bitten mensch gewesen als wien war
in eine loge unter anderem wurde der
platz von großmeister der loge war
märz von born soll die figur sein die
ein wenig in sarastro der zauberflöte
weiterlebt und reinhold kam mit seinem
orden nicht zurecht und rechts vom baum
hat ihnen dann also zur flucht verholfen
er kam nach jena war zunächst also anti
könnte ich eingestellt war aus seiner
philosophischen biografie haus die wahl
mehr durch den rationalismus der kampf
voraus ging geprägt und hat dann in
weimar die tochter von des dichters
wieland kennen gelernt und auch
geheiratet
das war eine wahl also professur in jena
professor wie man damals sagte super
marios das ist also ein professor kenne
direkte stelle hat der ist also über die
zahl hinaus super nummer pavillons und
die zeit hinaus angestellt lebt also von
den höher geldern die damals bezahlt
werden müssen das ist gar nicht so lange
her ich habe als student noch lehrgeld
mozart beziehungsweise mich davon
befreien lassen können durch fleiß
prüfungen aber ich gab es damals noch so
wie vor 50 jahren
und diese davon lebt er einen von einem
kleinen gehalt wasser sander bekommen
reinhold hatte etwas begriffen eine
milliarde begriffen dass ganz
philosophie allgemeingültig währung aber
zugleich gesehen dass sie nicht
allgemein geltend ist das längst nicht
jeder mann überzeugt und er überlegte
sich wie kann ich denn eigentlich die
leute davon überzeugen dass der kampf
recht hat und das überlegt er sich vor
allen dingen und jedenfalls am anfang
seiner tätigkeit mit der 80er jahre
wir sind jetzt also bei 1793 überlegte
sich das zunächst einmal im hinsicht auf
die theoretische philosophie also wissen
von der natur reinhold kam auf die idee
da sagte also von der natur weiß ich
natürlich insofern ich mir das vorstelle
vorstellen jetzt nicht in dem sinn ich
mir was zu recht mache sondern ich
stelle mir vor ich bin hier mit ihnen in
dem hörsaal
sie stellen sich vor bitten wir sind
hier also vorstellung in diesem sinne
von wahrnehmung kann noch niemand
leugnen dass er vorstellt denn selbst
wenn er leugnet das so vorstellt der
muss er sich da vorstellen dass er
vorstellt der mithalten kann dass er
vorstellt wenn ich
vorstellungen leugnen will dann würde
ich sie wenigstens schon haben damit ich
sie leugnen kann man selber ist ja noch
vorstellung ich stelle mir vor dass ich
dachte dass ich vorstellungen haben also
vorstellungen habe ich notwendig was bei
dir überhaupt nicht bei bewusstsein
jemanden der nicht bei bewusstsein ist
muss man nicht reden mit dem kann man
gar nicht so viel machen also was gehört
denn eigentlich so fragt reinhold zu
einer vorstellung aber erst als jemand
der vorstellt also zweitens die
vorstellung selbst also ich hab jetzt
die vorstellung dass ich hier in einem
mörser bin kann jeder von ihnen mit mir
sagen und das gehört auch dazu dass wir
diese vorstellung auf etwas was denn da
nun ist ziehen also das nimmt einen
gegenstand wenn wir sagen wir sind hier
im hörsaal dann ist der hörsaal der für
uns kein fantasiegebilde sondern etwas
was für uns da wirklich da ist also zur
vorstellung gehören drei dinge das
objekt das vorgestellte objekt und der
gegenstand also die sache selbst das
lässt sich nicht leugnen
da will reinhold nun anfangen und seinen
zeitgenossen gigantische philosophie
nahe zu bringen
und das formuliert er dass die
vorstellungen ist in einem satz und
diesen satz auf den er dann sein
weiteres denken gründeten der des opera
das was darauf gründet einen grundsatz
und dieser satz lautet satz des
bewusstseins linda ihn im bewusstsein
wird die vorstellungen durch der subjekt
vom subjekt und objekt unterschieden und
auf beide bezogen dann aber noch einmal
ich habe also eine vorstellung die
beziehe ich offensichtlich auf mich
indem ich das ist meine vorstellung wird
sehe ich aber auch auf die sache nämlich
sage jetzt die vorstellung etwa jetzt
vom hörsaal
ich beziehe also beides auch wenn diese
drei momente aufeinander und ich
unterscheide sich auch voneinander was
selbstverständlich es mal gar nichts
aufeinander beziehen was man nicht
voneinander unterscheidet man gar nicht
so voneinander unterscheiden wenn man es
nicht worauf dadurch aufeinander bezieht
aus dem wechsel bedarf das ist also der
grundsatz von reinholz theoretische
philosophie mit der er mit dem er die
ganze philosophie sozusagen fundament
ihren will nun der verfasser des sed
muss sagt das gelesen also die beiden
der schulze und der 1 19 beide
professoren in jena schulzen
ordentlicher der anderen super marios
und dasding de mehr
das ist kein grundsatz was mache ich
denn jetzt überlegt in diesem grundsatz
sind noch zwei handlungen des geistes
vorausgesetzt nämlich das unterscheiden
und das beziehe diese tätigkeiten das
bewusstsein sind noch vorausgesetzt
damit überhaupt etwas aufeinander
bezogen oder voneinander unterschieden
werden kann ich von meinen vorstellungen
die vorstellungen von den dingen die sie
forschte angeblich vorstellen sollen
dann aber ist der grundsatz von reinhold
überhaupt keinen grundsatz ersetzt ja
etwas voraus unterscheiden und beziehen
und wenn wir etwas voraus gesetzt wird
kann es nicht gut als grundsatz
auftauchen im grundsatz hat gerne
voraussetzungen wenn ein grundsatz fest
wollen ist ein folgesatz
die kritik sieht fichte ein
mein holz ist immerhin ein leute ist
immerhin die spitze der seinerzeitigen
philosophie mit ganz versucht jack ahnt
noch weiter zu denken und zur fundierung
die kritik von insidious idee muss
greift aber gerade diese spitze an und
wichtel sieht diese kritik ein
was jetzt verzichten verlangt ist viel
eher sieht also die kritik einer
philosophie die er selber doch für
überzeugend gehalten hat ich sagte das
ist die spitze der seinerzeit
gegenwärtigen philosophie
also hat fichte niemanden zu dem er
gehen kann und sich bei ihm noch
erkundigen kann warum kaufen und das
lesen geht nicht er sich selber machen
und das tut er von dem moment an ist
fichte wohl derjenige der für uns der
große philosoph geworden ist er war
vorher auf den wegen anderer denker wie
kampf und reinhold jetzt muss er neuland
erobern sie sich selber den weg dazu
warnen
nun ist klar so sagen so etwa kann ich
die überlegung von wichtiges
charakterisierung manchmal unterscheidet
das bezieht man aufeinander was man
aneinander bezirk unterscheidet man das
sind unser akte des bewusstseins die
zusammenhänge und jetzt kommt die
überlegung fichtes wer ist es denn der
unterscheidet und bezieht
doch wohl dass eine uns selber bewusst
sein sonst hätten wir ja eigentlich hier
zu friedls bewusst sein es muss noch
eines und dasselbe sein was die beiden
leistungen unterziehen und mit einer
unterscheiden und beziehen selber
vollzieht
es ist ein und dasselbe bewusstsein sein
was bedeutet das
das bewusstsein muss bevor es alle
anderen akte vollzieht solche wie
unterscheiden und beziehen
doch bisher als grund akte aufgetaucht
sind
es muss sich als das eine und
selbstbewusstsein vollziehen
es muss sich als dasjenige kennen was
unterscheidet uns bezieht und was noch
alles möglich gemacht
unterscheiden und beziehen sind sicher
grund akte und so sowohl und wichtiger
aktie unseres bewusstseins aber nicht
der letzte akt der hat noch eine
bedingung vorher nämlich dass das
bewusstsein sich als dasselbe weiß dass
sich in allen differenzen akten
vollzieht
wenn sich jetzt gesagt habe wird sich
sicher kompliziert an das verdient aber
etwas was uns so meine ich doch nur
vertraut ist
wir alle wissen doch was bewusstsein ist
das haben wir noch nicht gelernt um es
zu lernen hätten wir ja schon
bewusstsein haben müssen lernen ist
darum bewusstsein sagt ich kann also gar
nicht lernen was bewusstsein ist ist die
schlechte voraussetzung ihres lernens
und beweisen kann ich erst recht nicht
dass ich bewusstsein ab denn beweisen
ist ja wohl bewusst sein sagt wie soll
ich mir denn beweisen dass ich
bewusstsein habe bin ich ganz haben geht
nicht wir wissen was willst du wirst
dann auch mal um nicht nur von fichte zu
zu reden
das kriegen wir ja auch mit wenn wir
platt und männern gelesen wird der
sklave von männern als beispiel genommen
an der kern soll eine quadrat von
dopplung leisten also soll sagen wie
groß die seite eines quadrates ist das
doppelt so viele flächen eggert hat wie
ein gelegen ist denn retter zweimal
daneben und hat sogar die es ihnen dann
auf oder zum dritten mal doch zu sagen
wie groß die seite ist da sagt der kerl
ein zeiss ich weiß es nicht
man sagt dass sogar das zumindest jetzt
haben wir ihnen genau da wo wir ihn
haben
oder wo ich in ihnen haben wir besser
setzt es ihm klar was wissen es und was
meinung ist
und das hat er nicht irgendwo her
ich habe es eigentlich gelehrt was hat
es auf sich selber gefunden
das bleibt dann erinnerungen also ist
die berühmte analysis lehrer im und
selbst muss ich doch das wissen finden
und ich kann es nicht irgendwo her haben
diesen grundgedanken platons hat also
fichte hier
ich weiß nie aber plattform bekannt das
team zu sein das in seinem schulbus
stock wenn man das lesen müssen das weiß
ich nicht
jedenfalls diesen grundgedanken hat
fichte wissen ist schlicht hin da aus
sich selbst nicht irgendwoher richtige
halte des wissens sondern die tätigkeit
des wissens und wenn wir wissen was
wissen lässt
und offensichtlich wissen wir es ohne
darüber zu reflektieren
dann können wir natürlich auch das eine
vom anderen unterscheiden also das eine
noch das andere beziehen
das bewusstsein so sagt sich ist sich
also so wie fichte jetzt reflektiert hat
seiner selbst bewusst
das hat einen analogen im alltag
jeder von uns weiß wenn er meint wenn
wir sagen ich muss es niemand erklären
wissen wir was kann uns auch niemand
beweisen erst recht können wir uns nicht
beweisen dass ich zu mir ich sage das
wissen wir schlechterdings und darin
siegten analogen zudem dass das wissen
sicht als wissen selbst weiß dass diese
unmittelbarkeit mit der wir wissen dass
ich bin und nicht sie ich bin
sie sind für sich ich bin für mich ich
bin müssen wir so ist es mit der dem
bewusstsein auch das weiß sich selbst
ohne es noch irgendwo hier nehmen zu
müssen und können uns aufnehmen zu
können und deshalb nimmt ich diesen
grund des bewusstseins ich das hat so
manchen missverständnissen geführt
darauf werde ich noch im lauf der zeit
dieses semesters einzugeben haben
richtig schreibt dieses ich was diese
unmittelbarkeit des bewusstseins
bezeichnet groß dass groß geschriebene
ich ist bitte nicht zu verwechseln mit
dem kleingeschriebenen das hat man das
ist analog was hier analog ist habe ich
jetzt gerade versucht ihnen klar zu
machen ich groß geschrieben ist nichtig
klein geschrieben
das ist ein moment unseres bewusstseins
was jeder der kleinen ich von sich sagen
kann in seinem bewusstsein hat denn
offensichtlich sind wir ja alle solche
gewesen die wenn sie schon nicht von
sich sagen können ein bewusstsein von
sich haben
das bewusstsein der förderung seinen
grund darin dass das bewusstsein sich
selbst als bewusstsein präsent ist
also das groß geschriebene ich es
keinesfalls eine person dass unser sohn
schreiben wir im klein-klein antworten
satz anfangen hier geht es also nicht
darum um die person sondern um etwas was
strukturell zu unserem bewusstsein
gehört und nur deshalb weil unser
bewusstsein ja letztendlich von
derselben struktur ist können wir uns
verständigen wenn wir nicht nur basis
der identität hätten aufgrund deren wir
miteinander reden
also hier sitzen ja auch einige unter
uns die nicht deutsch als muttersprache
haben aber wir müssen uns doch
verständigen und offensichtlich können
wir es wir können es aufgrund einer
struktur unseres bewusstseins sie
offensichtlich eine und dieselbe ist
das können wir nicht miteinander reden
und jetzt also was mir noch wichtig ist
weil ich da zum ersten mal jetzt darauf
hin untersuchen es noch in den nächsten
semester wochen beschäftigen wird was
fichte ich nimmt es also wirklich ein
struktur moment des bewusstseins dass
wir haben das ist nicht etwa so dass das
eine person darstellt es ist auch nicht
so dass mit fichte mit dem ich etwa
jetzt das bürgerliche bewusstsein dass
19 späten 18
jahrhunderts fast doppelt so etwas
dergleichen es mag sein dass die das
bürgerliche bewusstsein durchaus dazu
beigetragen hat dass jemand so
reflektiert aber es ist nicht das
bürgerliche bewusstsein was fichte im
auge hat sondern es ist ein grund moment
des bewusstseins was von adam und eva
bis zum letzten menschen ausgesetzt
werden muss wenn wir von einem
vernünftigen menschen reden
also es geht nicht um eine bestimmte
person wir es geht nicht um eine epoche
in der sich etwa im bewusstsein
artikulieren es geht um ein struktur
moment unseres bewusstseins und dann hat
auch die schwierigkeit fichte zu lesen
dieses ich gibt's nicht wie es hier am
flügel gibt und wie es uns personen hier
alle gibt es ist etwas was wir denken
lassen damit wir uns als vernünftige
wesen verstehen und wir wollen uns wenn
wir schon philosophie treiben doch
verstehen
also
das habe ich ihnen versucht zu zeigen
was fichte eigentlich in dieser
auseinandersetzung mit timo schulze
einerseits und reinhold andererseits
wiederum erreicht hat ja den anfang
gefunden anfangen lateinisch prinzipien
richtig ski das wofür ausgeben kann das
wort prinzip ist vielleicht etwas
missverständlich war das einem prinzip
etwas folglich könnte es auch nennen und
das mache ich jetzt lieber die
bedingungen der möglichkeit die als
allererste gedacht werden muss für unser
bewusstsein
von hier aus wird fichte versuchen klar
zu machen was eigentlich bewusstsein ist
das wird er in einer reihe von
veröffentlichungen und vorlesungen
entfalten das wird in den nächsten 20
jahre die aber noch zu leben nicht mehr
das macht ihn beschäftigen und dann wird
er durch denken
was ist nun jetzt hier geschehen
ich denke es ist schon etwas
erstaunliches geschehen also ein junger
mann der wurden sagen studienabbrecher
war
hier war auch nicht mit sich selber
einig kopf und herz fielen auseinander
nicht wahr einerseits wieder
selbstständig sein andererseits sie dass
ich als deterministisch und er kriegt
nicht auf die reihe wieder selbst wie er
sich als selbständig denken könnte und
andererseits überzeugt ihn auch der
vitamin ist muss letztendlich nicht
spiegelt sich übrigens in der bestimmung
des menschen auf die wir noch zu
sprechen kommen wieder alles zu einem
junger mann also schwieriger tel
schwieriges leben
er kommt durch die lektüre von kant zu
sich selbst
auf einmal ist er jemand dann landet
kann persönlich kennen der ihn geradezu
ins leben hinaus schubst
veröffentlichten text das ist gut
stell dir auf die eigenen beine du
kannst es und dann fängt er an zu
reflektieren fängt an noch
offensichtlicher vielleicht auch durch
seinen erfolg beflügelt fängt er an
nachzudenken kommt an die wirklich
fortgetrieben sste philosophie seiner
zeit und denkt selber jetzt weiter und
das alles in drei jahren
das ist eine persönlich ganz
erstaunliche entwicklung und sie führt
fichte wirklich an die spitze der
seinerzeitigen philosophie
das muss ich ihnen in den nächsten
sitzungen noch genauer entfalten was
dann passiert also dass die rezension
des npd muss die fichte geschrieben hat
wohl offensichtlich um die jahreswende
93 94
das land im februar 94 in der
allgemeinen literatur zeitung
in jena wird übrigens sehr bald erkannt
als wichtig ganz merkwürdig also
berliner kennt das ja bald als
gewichtige rezension und stelle misst
damals noch in tübingen student das wird
erkannt als wichtig und vechta hat hier
zum ersten mal wirklich dass
veröffentlicht was ihn sein leben lang
dann noch beschäftigen wird
das ist weil das selber bezeichnet das
auch schon mit recht das ist der anfang
des philosophierens für fichte gewesen
diese rezension des npd muss sie hat
übrigens auch andere folgen noch das
kann ich ihnen noch kurz samen reinholz
ich sagte ihnen der war in jener
professor so carius hat er einen ruf
bekommen auf eine ordentliche
professorin stelle in kiel
also hingegangen und da ist auch bis zu
seinem lebensende geblieben
die stelle war frei und sie wissen wer
der landesherr von jena war und wer
dessen superminister war das ein
bekannter mann namens goethe und der
punkt und hatte immer ein interesse an
möglichst leute heranzuziehen nach jener
die eigens zu sagen hatten
er ist der partie ja auch schon ein
neues protegiert und der guckte sich um
und meinte mit dem richter da könnte man
doch einen gewinn machen das sei doch
ein mann der so in der kantischen
richtung gehe so wie schon seinerzeit am
reinholz und erst dann auch durchgesetzt
dass fichte einem ruf nach jena bekam
fürchtet diesen ruf dann angenommen was
bleibt da noch übrig und es wäre
vielleicht besser gewesen hätten noch
ein paar jahre in ruhe gehabt und
nachzudenken er hat das nicht er hat
also den ruf angenommen war in zürich
ersten der ruf erreichte hatte ja doch
geheiratet lebte im hause an und hat
dann in zürich schon eine reihe von
überlegungen zu papier gebracht
ganz merkwürdige texte also
normalerweise liest ich vielleicht
jemand diese manuskript sechste ich muss
dazu sagen fichte hatte so den den ja
die sitze für sich dass er das wenige
was er dachte auch auf schrieb er hat
nicht nur vor sich hin gedacht sondern
das gedacht auch zu papier gebracht und
diese aufzeichnungen haben sie also
erhalten sehr enthalten also eine reihe
von gedanken die erst in den späteren
lebensjahren fichtes wirklich
durchgezogen worden sind der ruf nach
jenem bringt dann in dazu dass er
erstens mal auf die bitte von lavater
rabatte rafa war am grossmünster in
zürich und in sankt peter
wenn man müsste die physiognomien
bekannt ist
diese rabatte hat in gebeten in seinem
haus ein paar vorlesungen zu halten
durch die museums rezension was ich dir
schon ein bisschen mehr ganz das hat er
auch gemacht das war das letzte was er
in zürich gemacht hat und es dann nach
jener gegangen und hat sich dort mit
einer schrift vorgestellt die zeigen
sollte was er machen werden über den
begriff der wissenschafts lehrer oder
die sogenannten philosophie die wird der
gegenstand unserer nächsten
zusammenkunft sein
soweit für heute